good evening
members
uh officers ladies and gentlemen welcome
to this meeting of the development
committee on the 23rd of November
2023 I'll Now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement there are no
planned fire drills so if the alarm goes
off please pleas leave the building in
an orderly fashion through the nearest
fire exit please use either the fire
exit through the main doors the hall or
the fire exit to the store room adjacent
to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance of
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council staff please note that the
meeting will be live streamed and please
switch off mobiles or turn them to
silent members of the public are
reminded that this is an official
council meeting and the applications
will be debated according to procedure
rules set out in the council's
Constitution members of the public can
you please note you are not permitted to
speak at this meeting unless you've
registered to speak with Democratic
services in this way everyone present
will be able to hear the debate and
counselors will be able to make an
informed
decision can I please also remind you to
be respectful of all those attending the
meeting including other members of the
public counselors and
officers members of the public while you
can of course film or take photographs
during the meeting this should be done
without disrupting the meeting and can
only be done from a designated area in
the public seating can I please
therefore ask you to raise your hand
clearly in the air if you wish to take
photographs or film this
evening I see no hands okay thank
you members your voice will only be
captured on the live stream when your
microphone is switched on so please
remember to switch on your microphone
when you are invited to speak and switch
off again when not
speaking members voting will be done on
a show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for for and then against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from the
voting items one and two apologies for
absence and substit uh substitutes we've
received apologies for absence from
councelor Stanley councelor Knight and
councelor
Meers councelor James Newport is
substituting for councelor
Stanley councelor uh Michael Hoy is
substituting for counc Knight and
councelor Arthur Williams is
substituting for councelor
Myers non-members attending I believe we
have councelor lambor and councelor
won and councelor
Mill have I missed anyone no okay good
thank
you minutes of the meeting held on the
28th September
2023 now before I ask for agreement on
this one uh members I have had
communication from a uh a resident um
making a point about this and I have to
point out that the purpose of the record
of the minutes is to provide a formal
record of the decisions made it is not
necessarily Verbatim what is actually
being said in the meeting so that being
clear members are we agreed that on the
uh meeting the minutes of the meeting
held on the 28th of September
23 agre agreed yeah okay thank
you item five to receive Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest members councelor
Ward member of L Town Council if that's
[Music]
pertinent Council M Shaw as it's County
councelor if that's
necessary counselor Mrs
Wilson uh thank you chair my declaration
of interest is is that I spoke at the
previous meeting regarding a agenda item
and that being Grovewood primary
school thank you thank you now um
chairman
sorry councilor Hoy sorry I missed you
there on advice from um ton Nukem I'm
just not declaring interest but I'm just
making it clear that um tonight I may
mention or it may be mentioned about 3G
pictures and policies around plastic
pictures and as lead member for climate
I'm leading on a development of policy
on that within the council so it's not
Declaration of interest but just to be
open and transparent I've been advised
to say that okay thank you any others oh
hang on uh councelor Ward thank you very
much chairman also on item number seven
regarding Grovewood I will need to
recuse myself as involvement in this
previously as portfolio holder for
strategic planning okay thank
you any other thing members any other
declarations no
okay um members in accordance with
committee procedure rule 9C I'd like to
move a motion without notice to change
the order of the business on the agenda
so that we take item seven first do I
have a
seconder councelor Mrs
Wilson all those in
favor
okay we can uh go ahead with that
then now before we start on
that
okay sorry for the delay there um yes so
if we could proceed with the uh report
there please and that would be Mike strs
thank you very
much I'm sorry Council Ward do I need to
leave at this
moment
okay
give me a moment please
members uh as the vice chairman
counselor Mrs vilmer Wilson has declared
an interest in this item this also
applies to council Ward as well um uh
they will be retiring from the meeting
just for this item I'd like to move a
motion without notice that Council FY is
appointed as Vice chairman for this item
only do I have a second please councel
Mr
Wilson all those in
favor y okay we have a majority on that
so if uh the two of you would like to
just leave for this meeting thank you
very
much
[Music]
thank you councelor fy and now over to
Mike strengths thank you thank you
chairman um this application is to a
site you can see in the Bold line here
um it's Grove Road extends along this
top here is this envelope of school
buildings Clarence road to the uh to the
west of the site and War Road and War
green um to the south of the application
area If U members uh see this site in
March this year it's an application as
you can see from the description for uh
a multi-use games area muger or
AstroTurf if you like um facility for
the existing skull if we could see the
allocations Pam
pees um chairman you'll see that the
green coloring on this plan is the green
belt and the school sits in an area of
just allocation of for school purposes
but the playing field is um also in the
green belt so the the the school
ownership if you like or the school
whole site is split between the
buildings not being in the green belt
and the playing field herea where the
words you see Grove and primary where
the site of the pr pitches is actually
located in the green belt if we could
jump back to 03 please um as I said
earlier the site you'll see here the
smaller area bold outlined is the
location of the pitch if we could jump
to the aerial view we have an directly
overhead shot we see here of the
proposed layout there's a number of
pitches playing both Crossways and in
different directions as well as the full
size because the pitch proposed gives
various capability for different types
of games and sports but this gives a
useful um location of the the proposed
facility in relation to the adjoining
Gardens we see here in Clarence Road and
War green um to the South to get our
bearings on site if you recall we were
able to walk around the perimeter
footpath in the school grounds and it's
inside that distance about 8 meters or
so here and I think it's 11 or 12 um in
that direction it's not uh Square to the
boundary because the boundary skews away
hence why um there's a a skewing
relationship to the site if we could see
the um position plan which I think just
repeats what I was saying now this is
useful actually chairman shows the
access um into the pitch there is a club
that uses the uh site on a Saturday
morning and like ourselves when we
visited the site you can come into the
car park here and journey through um to
the site in that
position if we could jump to the
elevations please chairman the pitch
itself is enclosed by a 3 meter high
mesh fence and here we also see on this
elevation some slight uh reforming of
the ground although the pitch is sort of
flat there's a gentle slope through the
site and of necessity they would have to
what we call cut and fill um you know
take some soil away redis it to level
the site up compact it but there's an
amount of spoil if we jump to um the uh
Next plan I think it's
09 there we see at the end of the
um proposal the Surplus cut soil if you
like will be redistributed in this area
in in Mounds that the highight point
it's over I think um point4 something of
a meter less than half a meter in height
and around the toe of the uh mounding
you'll see there is drainage to capture
any runoff take it into the drainage
system and connect to the sko drains
you'll also see that the pitch itself
has a series of drains through it and
then the slight slope very slight slope
to allow for drainage with these orange
arrows to show you the approximate
direction of
flow um as I say if we go to the section
plan please
08 there's been some views expressed
about how these are constructed and
you'll see that the uh resultant surface
is dug in with the dra brains that I was
referring to there's then a um what we
call a type three uh gravel grade mix
that goes over the top then you'll see
that there's a uh thinner uh aggregate
over the top of that then there is a
layer of Madam and then there's a a pad
um proposed now we've asked the
applicant about this and they've
confirmed today that it's made by
something that's
called which is styrene badine rubber um
it's granules basically from recycled
tires the process is that the um tires
are machined and ground down the the
steel wire that you find in the tires is
taken away the dust and other impurities
so you get more or less clean rubber
that is put on the site and then bound
with a granule and that takes maybe a
day or two depending on the weather
conditions to form solid and then over
the top of that is the uh playing what
they call the playing carpet the actual
Turf that that people um would play on
the uh life roughly of the pad is about
20 years which they say is is two carpet
lives so they would expect the playing
surface depending on where and tear and
conditions to last say 10 years or
thereabouts um if we then jump to Plan 9
please this is the as I show before the
approximate layout and that that gives
you the
context um with the exception of a
long-standing 15-year Arrangement that
the schoolers had with Ry boys to use
this on a Saturday morning or to use
their existing pitches on a Saturday
morning the proposed pitch is for the
purposes of the school they work to
hours at 7:15 to 6 p.m. in the evening
7:15 in the morning to 6 p.m in the
evening which allows for preschool clubs
and after school activities um and from
time to time if the uh ra users can't um
the r boys you can't use it on a
Saturday morning because of water
logging on the pitch they'd be expected
perhaps to to use this instead but
currently they use part of the school
playing field um on a Saturday morning
that Arrangement would would contain
would
maintain the proposal equates to an
appropriate facility for outdoor sport
in the green belt we mentioned at the
beginning of this that the site or this
part of the site is allocated green belt
green belt policy allows um permission
to be granted in principle for um
recreational uses for outdoor sport uses
like that we see from time to time at
this committee so in that basis it
wouldn't be termed inappropriate
development and hence the way the
offices are
recommending um you'll see on conditions
three and four of the recommendation
that we're limiting the use toess as it
has been so far and a condition about
lighting although lighting columns
usually require permission in their own
right the case officer has anticipated
their might be some use of portable
lighting so to cover that um where you
might not have expected to see a
lighting condition there's one in this
case the impact in immunity terms is if
you think that the school playing field
can be used by the school for activities
those activities wouldn't change you'll
still see um children playing out there
the background ambient noises there
might be some intensity in use because
obviously the flexibility that this site
allows um might generate that that
particular area used a little more often
that than it would be if it was grass
particularly in Winter periods when it
might be a bit water logged and
therefore they can't play on it without
wearing it out but the report you'll see
generally argues that with some
modifications or um adaptations you see
the point about the way the fence is
fixed certain types of uh fixing to the
post which reduces noise those uh
matters are the subject of a planning
condition the fencing is required
obviously to stop erant balls falling
all around the playing field and then
people treading in mud from the field
onto the surface but there's also been
uh we're told by the applicants
occasions where there's been abuse of
the school field people getting in their
after school hours as well as animals um
you know possibly abusing the the pitch
as well so uh it's of necessity to
contain the balls to keep the the site
in reasonable condition and to make it
secure they need to have uh fencing now
in drainage terms there's been some
issues raised about that it sits in a in
a hollow there's a general drainage
movement of water that flows through the
site um and it's identifi as what we
call a critical drainage area because of
that the applicants are conscious of
that hence why they've undertook the
drainage that you can see in this
diagram that would connect to the
existing school system and would have a
restrictor in it like you see on some of
the residential schemes whereby the
water is held back and can only Force
through a certain sized opening whatever
the amount of volume of water behind it
so it's a slow release idea that means
when the storm abates the water can
still continue to trickle away rather
than rush into the system which all
these things are designed to to avoid um
in conclusion chairman the applicants
have addressed the concerns that arose
uh from Members back in
January the officer report is extensive
and detailed and I don't begin to try
and summarize all of that here for you
tonight um there are a number of issues
raised about health concerns as and that
as officers we're not able to advise
these are you know some Medics wouldn't
even be able to tell you it's a
specialist thing to my mind the issue is
perhaps that similar to what we found
many years ago in Mobile phones there
are concerns there's a lot of
information on the internet there are
people worried um we're not in a
position as offices to help you with
that with the mobile phone system you'll
recall the government commissioned um a
QC to hear various specialist views
culminated in the Stuart report that
then fed into the advice and the
legislation that we currently work to
that's on mobile phones but it didn't
stop planning permission being granted
because normally the products and things
that are used in this process are
separately licensed or governed by
traded standards the only problem we
have is that the only opportunity people
get to express these concerns is through
the planning system because everything
else is dealt with in public public
inquiries or specialist things so it's
perhaps somewhat understandable why some
issues have been raised like this but I
think it's for members to to uh
determine what weight they give to these
things based on what we see in the
report where we've done our best to set
all the issues out clearly for you on
the addendum members will see that
there's further representations that the
case officer has replied comment to that
the recommendation is therefore approval
subject to the conditions set out in the
report thank you uh we have two public
speakers on this item the first speaker
is Mr Green Mr Green speaking in support
of the application please take your
place of the microphone you have five
minutes thank very much good evening my
name is Richard green sorry I'll go I'll
probably do it without it good evening
my name is Richard green and I'm head
teacher at Grovewood primary school I'm
going to begin by start stating that our
application to install a multi-use games
area aligns directly with the vision and
names of Rochford District council's
playing pitch strategy published in
November 2018 which in its 20-year
objectives states that it aims to create
a district that puts the health and
well-being of its residents at its heart
enabling and empowering its communities
to become healthier and more active by
providing greater opportunities for
recreation and exercise better
facilities and a higher standard for
sport and Leisure provision from
Grassroots to Elite at the previous
development committee meeting in January
a number of questions were raised which
led to the deferral of a decision being
made regarding gravewood application in
this meeting and on the portal a number
of assumptions and statements were made
and anecdotes shared by local residents
councilors and members of the committee
which without challenge or address which
were factually incorrect incorrect or
perpetuated mistruths about the proposed
scope of the project subsequently
through discussion these were accepted
as being fact and led to discussions on
matters that did not constitute material
planning considerations so for the sake
of clarity the muga was never Pro
proposed to be a 3G rubber crumb pitch
or a water-based pitch PCH it was always
designed to be a second generation
sandress pitch which could be used for a
wide range of activities and sports and
to provide an all weather alternative
when the field is unusable sandress
pitches have been in use for Deca in use
for decades specifically for tennis and
hockey and do not fall under the recent
EU ban on microplastics which is
specifically linked to the use of
recycled tires as 3G crumb infill
neither neither the UK or the EU has
proposed a total ban on artificial grass
in January's meeting some key questions
arrays leading to the decision to defer
and I'll address these in turn with
regard to drainage further technical
information has been submit submitted to
the lead local flood Authority which has
raised no objection and they have been
approved by them the SE the scheme
follows all sustainable drainage
principles in accordance with all
national and local Suds guidance as a
result of the proposal there will be no
flood increase off site as Grovewood is
the victim not the perpetrator of
flooding due to its geographical
location and the lead flood Authority
the competent Authority have approved
the scheme with the standard condition
that the three pre-commencement
conditions are satisfied and the
information checked by the LFA they have
clarified that it's not possible to
progress this further until approval is
granted a technical document posted to
the portal states that the service
surface poses no harm to man or
environment in addition sport England as
a statutory body has made no comment on
the proposed surface which it would have
done if it held any concerns with regard
to the safety of all the proposed
materials I once again draw members
attention to the fact that this is a
sandress pitch and contains no loose
rubber crumb this has been a common
misconception to address the necessity
for fencing it's principally there to
serve two purposes primarily it is there
to keep boards within the enclosure
maintaining the Integrity of the surface
and secondly for security reasons to
prevent unauthorized access at all other
times of there has as there have been
previous issues with trespass on
occasions from adjoining neighbors
accessing the school premises for their
own
purposes a full and thorough noise
impact assessment was commissioned and
carried out by DB consultation Limited
in April and the report issued in July
this report clearly states that the
noise levels generated by the proposed
muga including the fence would be no
greater than the noise already generated
by current use of the field and
recognizes that the noise of organized
PE in sport is significantly lower than
the noise of free play which already
takes place in the designated area our
plans meet all of the conditions
specified by Martin howlet of RDC in his
email of the 20th of
August Arch's ecological assessment
commissioned by the school was published
to the portal in June this report
clearly identifies that the biodiversity
of the site would not be compromised in
any way by the development suggestions
made as precautionary measures will be
implemented but the report makes clear
that there are no sets or other
protected habitats present which could
be
affected with regard to the use of the
muga Grovewood having a number of
occasions in writing clearly identified
that the typical times of use would be
between 7:15 a.m. and 6:00 p.m. we have
also agreed to the condition restricting
weekend use of the muga to a sole
Saturday morning left having sought
advice we understand that the imposition
of further restrictions on use would be
ultra viras as these would go beyond the
permissions and freedoms that already
exist to make use of our own facilities
for the benefit of our children and the
purposes of our
school I'd like to thank you for
providing me with the opportunity to
both respond to the points raised at the
previous meeting and to provide factual
accurate details about the background
rationale and scope of the application
for a facility that we believe would
significantly enhance the sporting
opportunities and wider health and
well-being of the pupils of Grovewood
primary thank you Mr Green Return to
your
seat second speaker is Mrs balding who
is objecting to the application on
behalf of residence Mrs bouring please
take your seat uh you have five minutes
to speak and I'll give you uh one minute
warning when you come towards the end
thank
[Music]
you good evening I'm John balding I'm a
resident and I'm representing over 170
residents who have signed a petition we
are the parents the grandparents the
Guardians and supporters of this school
and we strongly object to this
application we are here for the children
and to defend the protection of their
health and the environment the reason
for this application is I quote a small
section does get muddy in Winter and yet
despite the recent extreme weather this
playing field has been in constant use
the school has allocated over a quarter
of a million pounds for this for a
plastic carpet filled with silica sand
covering over half this plan
field this is an inappropriate
development and destruction of green
bell exceptions are only allowed as long
as they preserve the openness this
doesn't with a 3 m high fence and fences
are not including as exceptions and
therefore are harmful to the green belt
this is the primary school and has the
privilege of being custodians of
publicly funded land this is not a
sports center this is not for Community
use it is a place of learning for under
11s with a playing field this school is
already outstanding and has everything
and more for a primary school in this
County Public Health is a material
consideration this this is a risk to
Children's Health as they will be
exposed to microplastics and silica dust
the impact and pollution from
microplastics is deeply concerning for
everyone this is a carpet made of
synthetic Yarns filled with silica sand
fibers that will break down into the
soil and water systems in the form of
microplastics the synthetic trade
Council admits that yarn loss is
considered a secondary microplastic and
there will be loss of microfibers into
this environment
the manufacturers acknowledge that
silica dust is a risk to Children's
Health it can cause asthma and is known
carogen that can cause
cancer scientific research has reported
that chemicals leeching from plastic
particles are absorbed into tissues and
body fluids a microplastic pollution has
been detected in human blood for the
first time defra and now reviewing
emissions of microplastics this will
inform all future laws in the ukuk
the European commission have banned the
use of microplastics and artificial
pitches according to their research
fills with artificial grass are the
largest source of microplastics that are
released into the environment sport
England also says there are concerns
over the environmental impact of
artificial pitches and the fiber loss of
the
microplastics and closer to home Rocher
District Council have declared a climate
and ecological emergency a commitment to
becoming carbon neutral by 2030 plastic
grass has a sizable carbon print
footprint one plastic lawn is equivalent
to using hundreds of thousands of
plastic straws can you even begin to
imagine 2,600 square meters of this
plastic carpet this will increase your
carboned footprint
exponentially es County Council have
confirmed they do not promote the use of
artificial grass their climate report
says it the environmental officer has
confirmed it the flood risk officers
have also confirmed it compared to
natural grass well plastic grass
contributes to flooding it overheats to
extreme temperatures 34% of more
friction Burns and injuries are caused
it needs cleaning with chemicals it only
has approximately six years lifespan and
cannot easily be recycled in the UK it
does destroy biodiversity that cannot be
replaced natural grass it's safe it
takes up carbon dioxide it releases
oxygen acting as an air filter and it is
the green lungs of this
community for a small area that gets
muddy rather than covering up half of
this field in plastic with a cage the
most basic the most costeffective
solution is really simple upgrading the
existing drainage that's it job done as
a country we recognize that there is a
plastic transformation taking place we
do not want to become part of this toxic
Legacy we love where we live we love our
children we must protect their health
and their future setting examples by our
actions and not destroying this natural
environment we put our faith in you to
refuse this application on the grounds
of our health environment and the green
belt thank
you thank you Mrs
Bing now Ward members uh we have three
Ward members and they are councel Ward
who's obviously recused himself already
councel lambor and councelor mil do
either any of those Ward members wish to
speak would you like to come to the
microphone please thank you councelor
Mil thank you chairman um I haven't
prepared
a a precise speech but being involved in
this from the first time the application
was put forward to the council I was in
receipt of photographs of that flooded
field and flooded
Gardens and I've actually visited the
site on the development committee visit
saw children playing all over the field
and in the area which is nearest the
housing there was water collected and it
was actually um quite SN the ground and
it already has a mound of Earth all
around it from previous drainage Works
uh one thing that is of concern is that
the actual Topography of this field
seems to go uphill from where the
adjoining areas to the houses and what I
don't see in the drainage plan is any
form of water storage or pumping to take
it out of there
um and the fact that they're going to
make an even larger Mound at the back um
made me read some advice from the
industry about installing this type of
surface so I'm not talking about 2G 3G
we're talking about artificial grass
with drainage under it it says no matter
how many drainage holes and and how you
do it it would only do the job properly
if the ground is well prepared and I'm
quite pleased the council has got I
think conditions six and seven some
others to do with the drainage um that
that are in there but what the industry
says is Synthetic Turf has got a drain
field and will improve any type of
drainage that already exists and works
well but if there's a previous problem
the process will worsen it and the
client if they're asked does the water
drain well in this case it does not it's
a hollow or water
collects then what then happens is water
can remain stagnant for several days
underneath that surface so I don't see
the words pumping in here I see a a
consultant who talks about a Culver that
no one can find and I know for a fact
that the ditches are joining that school
owing to the flood Forum at this Council
were dug out in recent years but before
that they're almost up to ground level
and non-existent so how do we know
what's going to happen in the future now
there is another concern I know it's a
2G pitch the actual chemicals that are
in the grass itself the artificial grass
polypropylene and other substances but
there's quite a list of chemicals quoted
on the internet that's present just in
that material that's going to be run
about on by hundreds of children and
will break down so there's no doubt that
material will come out of it added to
that it's like a carpet unless it's
vacuumed or kept clean somehow or other
what tends to happen is detrius clex in
it and Sportsmen have had injuries with
streptococus infections and so on caused
by having injuries or skin injuries on
this type of material and more
worryingly I thought well it's going to
be sand under it no problem with that
now I find out that it's recycled tire
material but it's not in crumb form that
is underneath that yet again which is
going to be subject to wear so what
happens to this material remember we
have declared a climate and ecological
emergency that's what happens to this
stuff there's thousands of tons of it
once it's finished six years from now 10
years from now piled up in enormous
sites it has to go to landfill it's very
difficult to deal with and there we are
propagating it for the amount of money
they're spending could they not have
looked at the levels of that land looked
at the drainage of it taking it up and
adjusted all of that and dealt with it
in a much more sustainable
way uh so and the jewelry is still out
on artificial grass in Europe and their
class actions in America looking at the
deaths of professional athletes who've
been working on this type of material
playing on it professionally for years
suffering in Philadelphia six of them
have got the same type of brain cancer
so the the jury is out on this but at
the end of the day we know grass is safe
we know we can adjust levels
and drainage do we need to put in this
material thank you thank you councilor
Mill counc lamber do you want to speak
on this m please take the
seat as with everyone else you have five
minutes and I'll give you a the nod when
you come to a minute
left
sorry uh when I first came across this
application I was very interested as I
was a Founder pupil of Gro school all of
uh nearly 65 years ago and I well
remember this field being a um a pudding
made of Essex clay and uh not very
usable um often between November and
April and it would appear from the need
for this application that that still
applies I don't the um idea of upgrading
the existing Fields drainage must have
come up in the past but because of the
lay of the land I guess the water just
continues to run down and makes the
whole
area um a
pudding
um I did have a lot of other stuff
written down to say but what I would say
is we've heard a lot of quotes from
people who have done a few clicks and
searches on the internet um and I find
that if you look long enough you'll find
something to support whatever you want
to want to believe in this case I would
prefer to the
members um follow the guidance given to
them by professionals rather than
worrying about what somebody in um Ohio
might have thought about this or that so
I would ask that when we can when you
consider this yourselves and have your
own discussions you you um limit
yourselves purely to the
uh the facts and not loads of
hypothesis I don't envy your
um your uh
deliberations on this because it is a
difficult subject
but there are two sides the residents do
have a a very Cent View and they are
correcting some of what they say but
also we must remember we're talking
about the health of children not not
going
to what we've discussed with uh cogens
and all sorts of that we're just talking
about their physical health children
need time to play do things physical
activity and the idea from the school is
to to improve that so I'm not going to
make a recommendation to you but I would
just say you've got to be bear up bear
in mind both sides of the argument thank
you thank you Council
Lille now before we get into debate um
I'm sure every member here would have
been
bombarded uh by uh emails with regards
to this application um I certainly have
um I will say that I have read everyone
that I have been has come to me um but I
feel it would be uh wrong of the council
at this stage not to actually listen to
our legal councel which we have um Tom
mukum with us and I've asked him before
we debate just to give the legal view
from the council point of view so as we
know what basis we're working from so
Tom over to you please yes okay uh thank
you chair and thank you members um I
don't have an awful lot to say and uh
forgive me if I'm teaching you to suck
eggs because some of you would have been
on this committee for some time but
obviously what you need to do from a
legal point of view is make a decision
in accordance with planning law and so
section 386 of the of the 2004 uh
planning act uh determines that you need
to make these applications um in
accordance with the relevant policies of
the development plan unless there are
material considerations that indicate
otherwise um some of the issues all of
the issues that we've uh heard so far
this evening and are dealt with in the
report are capable of being material
considerations um impact on the Green
Belt uh drainage and uh impact on uh
physical health
wellbeing um you've got a very detailed
report in front of you which I'm sure
you've all read and there's also been
various pieces of evidence that have
been uh presented to you as part of this
application um so your job is to
consider what weight to place on that
information and that evidence and that
is a matter for you as to what weight
you will give um give the information
you've been provided with ultimately
you've had professional advice
uh in the form of your report and that
contains a recommendation but it is only
a recommendation it's up to you to carry
out the planning balance on the evidence
that's presented to you as to whether or
not this application should be approved
or
refused thank you Tom okay so moving on
from there um it's over to members uh
counselor Mrs
Shaw thank you on the addendum page
three 1.6
just want to ask the officer um it says
the biodiversity net gain based on the
10% Target which is not is not yet
activated and this is unlikely to come
into false until at least January 24th
are we rushing this application through
before that comes through on January 24
I just want clarification
please chairman I wouldn't accuse it of
rushing through you'll be aware that at
ations are timed so they are submitted
at a certain point in time and we should
be looking to deal with this sort of
thing in in eight weeks so I don't think
The Coincidence of this meeting against
that date is is somebody trying to get
something dealt with a head or whatever
of legislation coming in if if that
answers uh the query I think there's
some uncertainty about the barity ne CL
I don't know if anyone else wants to add
to
that thank you chair um just just for
clarification for the committee um the
biodiversity net gain the 10% was meant
to come into effect in November as I'm
sure um most of the members of this
committee will be aware the government
are still waiting on um further
information to come through um to enable
them to implement that
legislation um and at the moment it's
anticipated that it will be January but
um there is quite likely that it will be
extended Beyond January we've had no
further updates on
that thank you for the
clarification members any
other councilor
Wilson uh thank you
chairman I won't go over the points that
have been made by the other speakers um
but members should really bear in mind
that the field is already in use for the
health and well-being of the community
and so whatever decision we take tonight
whether we agree or or whether we
approve or whether we um refuse it that
facility will still be there so we're
not actually taking anything away
whatever we do with our decision
um to give you a bit of context I'm a
qualified fa coach and I've used the
type of surface that has been proposed
and what I would say is it's not a
Panacea these surfaces can flood and
they can freeze over and they can also
get so hot to the point of unusability
so it's it's it's not a Magic Bullet
that's going to solve all of the
problems I can't support the Lan of an
artificial um surface because I believe
it will permanently damage the um
environment once you lay those surfaces
down it it will destroy the soil so you
can never get that
back in addition that the mass of the
fencing around will um actually close
down the um amenity of and and visual
appearance of the Metropolitan green
belill and for me that's a noo so I
won't be able to support this
application thank you
chairman thank you Council Wilson
councel
Hoy thank you chairman again I'll try
not to repeat anything because I know
you don't like that um however I will
have to go in on the the surface of the
picture again there were we have we've
been told it isn't um rubber crumb in
the same way as a 3G picture but we are
told it is this the pad is made up of
recycled tires which may not be in the
same format as crumb so there is there
is a certain amount of that rubber which
will get into the ecosystem if you like
again the top of the pitch that might be
dressed in sand which was emphasized
quite a lot by the
Headmaster there is there are
still the blades are still made off
plastic I think it's probably poly proo
um that I I read about it however before
I go any further I just want to read
something from sport England sport
England seem rather confused about their
own policies at the
moment um they sport England issued a
position statement on plastic pitches in
April
2023 um it mentions about 3G but this
relates to all artificial grass pictures
and this is I hate you use the is
plastic pitch
um so it talks about artificial cross
peaches are recognized as a durable safe
year round playing surface which we we
all understand um it goes on in the next
paragraph to say however concerns have
been raised about the environmental
impact of these pitches most commonly
this relates to the fiber loss of
microplastics which is is in this case
the service and potentially the rubber
it talks about rubber crumb but this is
a slightly different rubber
um they're also aware of the potential
developments in the EU following the
European commission statement which was
released in September
um they have concerns of it which it
would appear that the people we spoke to
at sport England weren't aware of within
this
report in addition I'd like to add that
we as a council have declared a climate
and ecological
emergency um in addition to
that we have as a council been
instructed by the
administration
to
urgently develop a policy on 3G and
plastic pitches which is in progress
mean started but in progress
so I feel that this is quite awkward for
us because
obviously this is a situation where
we're developing a policy there's clear
indications that there are health risks
with this we believe which is not
something we've read off the internet
this is the European commission small
England are also worried about this and
and there is certainly a band coming in
the I've got concerns about the pad I've
got concerns around the end how how it's
dealt with as end of life we talk about
recycling it not really possible to
recycle it very easily potentially it
would go to landfill and most of all as
I've said I've got real real concerns
about these micr Plastics ending up in
the ecosystem around the school that's
what I'm going to say on that the next
point is the one I think at the previous
meeting I mentioned this about the
fence the fence has to have planning
position it is in the green belt and
it's in it is 3 m tall um on page
7.13 at the top of that page you got two
the effect on the openness of the green
belt obviously this is where the fences
mentioned this is a 3 m as far as we can
read close-nit fence which will have an
effect on the openness of the green
belt it cannot do anything but and I
don't believe there are I don't believe
that there are special circumstances or
very special circumstances or the sorry
I'll get my words right I don't believe
the very special
circumstances have been outweighed by
the need of the fence the the planing
pitch could be used perfectly use sorry
could I ask whoever's got that their
phone going in the audience there to
turn that off please thank you sorry I
didn't hear that chairman um the minute
to go so again I still have concerns
around the fence I don't
think the fence I don't agree with the
fence put it that way um they're the
main points thank you
chairman thank you any others members
wishing to speak Council
constable thank you Mr chairman um
there's been a lot said about the health
risks of this pitch and it mentions
Sport Styles being um exposed to it the
majority of the children will be playing
on this pitch will be for a period of
probably 45 minutes once maybe twice a
week so the risks to the children is not
the same as a professional athlete that
may be training and working on this
pitch all the time so so I can see this
as a big benefit to the school and to
the health of the children and their
sporting abilities and I don't have a
problem with um supporting this
application thank
you thank you any other members wish to
comment councelor
Newport thank you chairman um I just
wanted to um check with officers on
condition nine um in that condition it
if members were remed to approve this
would that condition also include having
the logs of Maintenance available for
inspection by the LPA because it it it
says in there about maintenance
activities and frequencies but a lot has
been said about flooding and drainage
but we would actually need to reassure
ourselves that the site was properly
being maintained and those logs are
available so that's one question for
officers
um the other just point I'd like to make
really is um quite a lot has been said
about health implications or possible
Health
implications we don't know in my mind
football match is 90 minutes so I don't
know if children will play on it for 90
minutes
but it's very inconclusive the evidence
that we've been presented here
but the same goes for other applications
that we've looked at in the past where
Health implications have been raised so
I think it's a very important issue for
members to think about these are these
are young people very young people
developing developing lungs and I for
one don't want to play Russian Rel with
their
health thank you any more comments from
anyone oh sorry Mike Str do you want to
come back first please thank you
chairman um depending how this goes if
members were to move approval um then
that move would require perhaps from the
if members agree that condition n be
varied to include as we often see with
other recommended conditions that the
maintenance schedule be made available
from time to time uh for inspection that
that can be
done
counc
Linden hello yes I just want to clarify
um from Mike's ranks did you actually
say that you're not able to supply us
with the information regarding the
health elements and the
dangers chairman you'll know I don't do
things briefly the brief answer is we
can't I've done my best to read much of
what I've seen that's been exchanged and
submitted to members and thinking that
members would expect of me to be able to
say well is this right or is this wrong
not being a medical
specialist I can't I can't tell you I
know that the material that you've um
been submitted some of it says the soand
so organization have found this which
might give that particular Point
credibility other points that you see
look like they're just like quotes on
paper that they nously been
sourced so members have to choose what
weight they give to those comments but
as a a planner of several years
experience I can't tell you what those
health risks are I'm not I'm not
qualified I have no better idea than you
do as to whether something will result
in people getting cancer or will not in
my presentation I alluded to we had a
similar problem many years ago with the
mobile phones and they the government
took that issue away examined it
and helped councils clarify this matter
what they actually did they introduced
something called an nner certificate
which means that if the kit complies
with the Government testing that it's
okay it's then safe for members of
councils to be approving so all the
applications you've seen since have all
been accompanied with an itnot
certificate that's an industry
government thing it wasn't something
that we could deal with as as a council
and I I think we're on the verge of
something similar here where there's a
lot of interest and concerns and anxiety
about these issues that are being
reported we perhaps don't know who to
trust which is one hell of a dilemma for
members here and now but I can't as a
planning
professional confirm or otherwise those
health
risks thank you for the clarity on that
Mike much appreciated um did I have
anyone else who wanted to to speak on
the matter coun
BR thank you chair um again to Mike have
we got any of evidence I'm sorry if I
haven't seen it in the report um I think
one of the speakers has actually
mentioned it and I've found this in in
different areas I've been looking at
that the actual Turf does freeze in the
winter the water can be retained so it
will freeze over and it does retain snow
and in the summer it doubles in heat do
we have any evidence in there that you
can advise on please chairman I don't
have any evidence but I've played on
such services in snow so I think it
depends like anything else there's a
period of time when the snow takes time
to clear or like we were doing we were
brushing it off so we could play so it
does sit like it does on any surface um
but the spec that we've been given in
this application they say that it is
porous there was some debate about the
fact that it has a Tac Adam layer I'm
not specialist in that but if the spec
says it is porous hence the drains
beneath then in Period of snow there
would be a period of melt which would no
doubt SE through some of it might be
removed by caretakers or players or
whatever so they can get on with their
game um I think I see something
somewhere else in the particulars that
in strong storms they probably wouldn't
play the game would be called off even
though it's AstroTurf so um they do
capture water because they're a surface
and like any surface there's a period of
time whether it be rain or snow that it
dissipates away they also get hot
because of the nature like anything in
the in the um hot weather like saw this
summer with some of the extreme
temperatures things that are manmade
warm up so you do have a heat problem
perhaps you do have a drainage issue
where they capture it the people who
manufacture these try to deal with that
as as best they can but that the
extremes will always present either
piles of snow or possibly a hot
surface thank you Mike you want to come
back um just going back to the heat
subject um I mean what I've been reading
is it becomes unbearably hot and it can
burn is this what you're saying it's
therefore they won't be able to use the
pitches at these
times I think chairman it would be up
for whoever's running the event you know
we see sometimes with grass pitches that
matches are called off because the pitch
is Frozen we um have sometimes uh
manmade like cars you touch a car in in
the extreme weather you can you canh
burn yourself The Desert Rats used to
fry eggs on their Land Rovers in the war
if youve got a man-made
material the temperature of the day will
affect it and I think if if you got
children being exposed to the heat it's
perhaps down to the management of the
game or the school activity to perhaps
have a look first and say we won't play
on that today it's too hot there might
be a risk of burns um I'm not sure it
would be something for this committee to
to get into as to whether if granting
permission will result in Burns
because the planning issues are the
provision of the facility and the issues
that have been talked about the actual
Health consequences of the likelihood of
obtaining a burn I don't think are a
planning planning question but I can't
rule out that if somebody was to touch
the surface on an exceptionally hot day
they might get burnt so similarly if it
was icy conditions they could fall over
and hurt themselves just like they can
on on other other services when we play
rugby with regular breaks if these you
know only the rugger guys that were out
playing on the football as were inside
so you know it's down to whoever's
running the management of the game or
the practice session as to whether they
I think deem it safe rather than the
planning
decision thank you Mike councelor Hoy
sorry chairman just wanted to come back
because I probably didn't phrase it very
well as a question but I mentioned about
the um recycle tires used as a pad and I
just wanted if Mr Shank
knew how different they are to the
rubber crumb used in 3G
pitches I'm not not sure we have an
answer for that chairman I actually own
two of them um I have a special use for
them on a trailer to stop the load
bouncing because the pad is a shock
absorber the upside down of it is like
an egg boox so the um the it's it's a
it's a
coned
material and those I've had three or
four years they don't I haven't seen
them break off but they're used only
occasionally but I think it's because of
the chemicals that are involved the
resins and everything else I think that
may be limiting the recycling you know
there's certain things we Chuck in our
bins which can't be recycled there's
other things that that can because
there's a process for recycling them um
but if it does result in piles
of a material that has no other use
whether they can't use it in Road making
or it has to go to landfill as you've
heard tonight that's a a consequence of
this material it exists because it's a
reuse of it's a second life to some of
the material that's already been used
say in the making of tires so
um it it can be used like people like me
who might have a certain need for it use
it as a weight or something in in other
things or are pollings um but if it does
result in mouns of this thing to
landfill that is a consequence but it's
already been used
once thank you uh one last come back it
was just to come back because I think
what I was trying to get out was that
this material that is proposed for this
mugger as they're calling it would still
deteriorate and get into the ecosystem
as in the same way as rubber crumb would
or maybe a different rates of rubber rum
but we still do that I don't have any
information chairman on the
deterioration rate the ones I'm familiar
with are are solid and they should go
and physically break something off I
think the issue that's been rehearsed
around
um the rubber crumb is like you see in
horse marges or surfaces where it's it's
it's it's spread on the top to allow
bounce or or ping activity and when it's
rained off that's when it enters the
system or like other people have been
saying if you got the blades that
because of wear they become dust and so
forth but the the sub ler is buried
between the plain carpet so it's not so
exposed to the direct heat or the
weather
that the top surface would
be thank you okay unless we have any
other new members comments on that I'd
like to just sum up okay so as I said
when we first started this debate I have
had a mountain of uh emails and
submissions to myself uh about this
issue uh I have read everyone and um I
have to comment on one thing that I
found rather disturbing in that some of
the language used was quite inflammatory
and um quite uh regrettable let me say
um we're talking about this this
particular pitch being
2G a lot of the furora that's actually
come up around these these kind of
pitches is around 3G and a lot of the
emotion that has come up out of this has
been because of the issues around 3G
pitches um and I in reading a lot of the
emails that have come to me there's a
lot of emotion that has come around this
and there is a danger in that because
you become emotionally involved and you
become intransigent in your particular
way whether it be for or
against um sport England they did put
out a uh a statement about a couple of
weeks
ago saying that following the EU
directive that they were looking at 3G
pitches but with our officers have as a
result of that they have contacted sport
England again to ask for their um
opinion as to whether they would change
their mind based on that on this
particular type of pitch they have come
back and they have said categorically no
so they are not condemning this
particular type of
pitch when it comes to uh greenb um this
particular
uh area of
land is a sports playing
area it's not going to change it's still
going to be a sports playing area so
then it becomes an issue of
balance and that is what we as a
committee are commissioned to do we are
commissioned to look at the the fors and
against and we are asked to draw a
balanced conclusion from
it
the one thing that um I've gleaned from
the information that is coming is that
there would be a lot more opportunities
for the pupils in the school to explore
other
sports and to be able to do them in
different times of the year now for
whatever you think about putting grass
in and using that all year round in a
school environment I I from what I read
that's quite
impractical so on balance how do we look
at this
this is a 2G pitch not a 3G pitch the
drainage has been dealt with in the uh
report and in subsequent uh items that
uh the school have had to get done in uh
reports
additionally um the health issue we have
to have a balance here now is there more
Health through getting our kids outside
at times when they would be sitting
inside in front of their
screens learning how to do other
sports it's a
balance the uh the school
itself we've heard are an outstanding
school they are looking to promote
things that are going to keep that
standard they're going to put these
pupils in a position where they do have
the
extra ability
to do Sports to be outside to be in the
fresh
air for myself I look at it on balance
now I for one am very very keen on
anything that actually promotes a green
issue what is actually happening under
the proposals here is that the
biodiversity is actually likely to be
increased with some of the stuff that's
being put in it is I find it very
strange that people people say that
there is
biodiversity that is going to be lost on
a pitch which is basically going to be
mud and then you look at situations
where there are trees that are going to
be put
in and they will promote a lot of
biodiversity the on balance I look at it
and I think that we need to actually
take notice of what our officers have
actually brought in front of
us and we need to be aware that if we
are going to
uh refuse this particular application
that we need to be on Solid Ground in
our refusal and that means we need to be
absolutely sure that if this goes to
appeal that it won't be lost so with
that in mind I think we will now go to
the
vote sorry honor of order chairman could
I just say are you saying that we should
be voting on the basis of whether or not
this will go to appeal
no absolutely not no absolutely not my
ears heard something different I'm glad
you no I I am not saying that at all but
I do say that we do need to take notice
of what our officers have actually
recommended so with the respect to um
the recommendation is to approve the
application subject to the condition set
out in Pages 7.2 to 7.5 of the report
can members in
favor yeah I'm going to move it from the
chair for acceptance do I have a second
sorry I have uh Mr strength wants to
come in on chairman forgive the
interrupt I don't know if this uh vote
includes the amendment to condition nine
suggested by Council and
Newport if we approve it yes so that
will have to be part of the amendment
that Council Newport has asked for can
you just clarify what that amendment is
please
counc the logs of maintenance
be included for inspection by the
LPA for the flood surface
water right we need to take a vote to
get that added for a start off so uh
those in favor of the amendment please
uh can I have a second I sorry first I
uh so Mr Newport you're proposing it
second Council FD those in favor please
indicate
those
against any
extensions thank you that amendment is
passed so now we go on to the
substantial
recommendation uh I will recommend from
the chair that we approve application
subject to the conditions set out on
pages 7.2 to 7.5 of the report do I have
a second up Council
conable okay those in
favor those
against two three four
five thank you chair could I have my
vote recorded please certainly thank
[Music]
you and Council Hoy as well once
recorded
thank you
abstentions okay that application is
refused thank
you sorry hang on a minute hang on just
a minute
sorry right sorry I do do apologize that
now needs to to go to reasons for
refusal all right I need a member to uh
move a recommendation for
refusal do I have a okay councilor
Hoy thank you I'll take the hot
seat um refusal reason number one
um
inappropri of the um or the the 3 meter
high fence not outweighing the special
circumstances of green belt
development that's number one yeah is
that okay I'm just making sure that the
officers are happy with
that the
wording secondly this is the more
difficult one to word obviously
but with regard
to emerging Council
policy and mppf paragraph 92 which
refers to health and
safety of users that the use of
artificial plastic the use of the rubber
pad the use of
theadom
underlay POS
pose problems with
the with the breakdown of of those
materials into the
ecosystem chairman I'll being notifi
point of Mr chairman they can't hear a
point of order though you can't have um
something against the policy that
doesn't exist if you haven't got a
policy how can you say something is
against that policy if it doesn't exist
so on a matter of chairman I'm sure
emerging policy is perfectly valid
within the local
plan I'm being advised that it's not so
I think you need to to revise
your can I just refer to our legal
representative please do do we actually
have an emerging policy I'm not not
aware that there actually is one
yet it depends what you call by emerging
there is a local plan which is emerging
and there's a um the initial meeting has
taken place between officers and there's
been a report done by one of the
officers around artificial grass
pictures and it's been referred to The
Climate committee so I would suggest
that is emerging I I personally as a
legal representative I would I would
advise against referring to that uh it
sounds as though it's in an extremely
early stage and therefore I would say
very little weight could be could be
placed on the emerging policy that
doesn't mean that your reason for
refusal couldn't be crafted in in a
different way but I I don't think
referring to a policy at that much an
early stag is would would be acceptable
that's fine then thank you I I would
take out the reference to emerging
policy so um the uh refusing on the Bas
on of Health grounds on the basis of the
breakdown of the known breakdown
of
the polyethylene which I believe it is
made of on the surface the rubber tire
pad and The Madam underlay together with
silica
sand in relation I believe it is mpf 90
paragraph 92 which which it it says
health and
safety so I'm taking mean some of the
health and safety is about other things
other
than the physical health called by these
things but I'm suggesting that that
that's where why I'm putting it on those
faces
okay wants to wants to come back
chairman just briefly we like University
challenge up here working on an answer
but to help you with the policy an
emerging issue okay in in planning the
the policy gains weight and hopefully
Phil will correct me if I'm wrong and
gravitas the more processes it's gone
through through to adoption so if you're
at a very early stage of your local plan
like like we are I I don't know unless
Phil tells me otherwise if we're much
beyond the call for sites as regards of
drafting policies that have then been
put out to consultation and then you've
had feedback from that consultation that
takes it to other stages if that
feedback from the community or whatever
and the professional out there doesn't
change or necessitate the change to the
text or only part of that text that
policy starts to survive the various
stages that it goes through and the more
stages it's gone through the more weight
that you can give it now if this policy
perhaps hasn't been to committee I don't
know it's not not a planning policy I
don't believe if it's a corporate policy
it has perhaps less weight than your
your planning policies So I'm mean I'm
in your hands as to what um the origins
of this are and how far it's gone if
it's an idea then great idea as that may
be in planning it has a lot less weight
than if you like your your local uh
policies thank you I'd i' remove the the
part referring to emerging policies so I
was referring to the um mppf paragraph
92 which is around health and
safety
um that's
not it it uses the word
to make sure the places are safe and
accessible by safe so they are safe to
use I'm saying that they're not safe to
use um Healthy Lifestyles I don't
believe there that these are can be
healthy I it it is quite clear you I can
state it again that the degradation of
the polyethylene on the top surface
the rubber
infill pad and the mechm underlying that
will
degrade and will affect the health of
the users and will'll get into the
ecosystem and and affects the health of
other people that
way we've been told that this is a we've
been told at the beginning of this by
Tom Nukem that that was a valid reason
there was nothing not valid and we're
putting a lot of weight on
that I'm using the mpf paragraph
92 for that can we just be concise on
the reasons for refusal um so uh Ivon
can I ask for
clarification yeah I just want to um be
clear
that
Health safe health and safety with
regards to materials that are being used
in the construction of the pitch are
matters that are outside of the planning
legislation
it's like it's like any building
material you know we wouldn't be um
saying that um you know I mean there
concrete concrete dust can be cogenic
but that doesn't stop planning
permission being granted for sorry if I
may interrupt um
chairman I propose this on the basis
that we were told by
our legal advisor that all these points
would be valid or could be valid it was
quite clear that this is one of the key
points that had been raised
by with within the addendum within the
report and at our last meeting to some
extent can I can I now being told it
isn't a valid reason yeah can I ask for
uh for Tom to actually clarify this then
please because he's going backwards and
forward you need to get some conclusion
here sorry I think yeah I
mean as as you can see in the in the
mppf for for example um impact on on
public health of a proposal is capable
of being a material consideration but
but I but I do agree that I think we've
got to be careful here what we're
actually saying because the the precise
materials that might be used in any
particular
proposal um is likely to be a matter
that's outside the remit of of of of
planning and the planning officers remit
so you know for example one might be
able to consider a condition that
required subm of materials to be
approved by the the the planning
officers but the planning officers
themselves under those circumstances
would only be able to do that within the
RS of the AR of their own expertise
which is in relation to planning and the
the precise com chemical composition of
materials Etc would be dealt with by
other legislation so I think I
understand what you're saying and I
understand the vote that's been that's
been taken here and and the next steps
that need to be taken but I just think
you you need to be you need to be
careful about how and why and what it is
that you're that you're drafting in
terms of your reasons for refusal so I
think if you if you can pin those to uh
a policy within the uh development plan
or within the mppf that you consider um
that these proposals are are not in
accordance with I think that is going to
that's going to be very helpful to your
officers in drafting the
refusal um you know I think I think
members need to be clear exactly what it
is what is the reason that that you are
uh about to be asked to vote uh on a
refusal okay thank you Tom um so
councilor Hoy on that basis then can we
have clarification on what you are
suggesting as reasons for refusal I was
taking initial advice from Tom Nukem
when he gave us the talk at the
beginning of the session I looked at the
mppf and related it to that I have not
yet related it to our own policies I've
need to take a um 5 minute pause to to
check our policies I haven't got them in
front of me I normally remember many of
them off top of my head but I can't
remember the ones around this at this
point and I don't have it in front of
me okay I'm minded to give you five
minutes and five minutes strictly only
sorry Mike if you got something to say
on that chairman listening to the um
conversation and looking at paragraph 9
to I'd like if members wish to readback
a reason formulated from what I've heard
if that helps things and helps yourself
that would be very helpful thank you
thank you chair um so the reason we're
gleaning uh suggested by members is as
follows the proposal by way of the use
of plastic recycled rubber particles in
Brackets recycled tires and silicate
would with wear and tear result in
particulates entering the environment
contrary to paragraph 92 of the mppf
which seeks to provide safe and
accessible green
infrastructure C are you happy with that
I think he says it much better than I
did I'm I'm happy with that from a legal
point of view provided the the planning
team are happy that that's an acceptable
reason for refusal from a planning point
of
view we'd give it a go chairman I can't
promise the outcome but listening to the
debate putting together in the context
of this it's probably something we could
work with and if you throw in the issues
that the public have that have entered
this issue it has some some legs as
somebody might say but I can't I'm not
forecasting that it's robust for an
outcome only time would tell and it
being tested I go back to the mobile
phone issues things like this that we
had years ago same kind of same kind of
process but I think it's good enough
okay thank you for your input there Mike
appreciate that chairman if I may add
something I'd like to thank M Mike trks
for that but I do personally feel this
is a really important matter and I think
even if we are a test case on this I
think it's important that this goes
ahead so you're happy with the
recommendation for refusal that Mike has
formulated from what the conversation is
yeah in addition to the refusal based on
the um fence in addition to the
fence Mike ch um while I was doing that
cla's been working on the fence one so
we have we have a fence reason as well
do do you wish that to be read just for
for clarity or yes I think that would be
wise thank you so reason two I've read
out reason one The Proposal would be
considered to represent inappropriate
development within the green belt
contrary to paragraph 149 of the mppf no
very special circumstances are
considered to exist that would outweigh
the harm to the green belt
identified specifically fence the fence
sorry did have me that right at the
first two words the fence but we've got
it written down J okay thank you now are
we members are we all clear on what
those reasons for refusal
are yes okay I need a proposer I'll
propose it councilor High and a seconder
please councelor Wilson okay all those
in favor of the reasons for refusal
please
indicate four
five
thank you all those
against
exensions I'm not vo I this is just
stupid okay that's five for uh three
against one exstension so the uh refus
is complete on that thank you so at this
point um we obviously have quite a full
program to go on to next uh uh members
of the public you are welcome to
stay um I would suggest maybe a very
quick five minutes Comfort break and I
will make it strictly five minutes so if
you want to come back at at 9:00 and we
will reconvene then thank
you
sorry members can we reconvene
please
[Music]
we have um items to get through that I
want to get through as much as we can
but I am minded after the last meeting
that we had that we are not going to go
on anywhere near that sort of time so
please with that in mind do bear in mind
with your comments to be concise Etc um
now item we're going back to item
six
now
[Music]
item number seven is uh land east of All
Saints church and north of arendel Road
vridge Road ashington Katy Rogers will
present the officers report thank you
Kae thank
you the application site is formed of
two main Parcels of land which are
located in an area of Farmland north of
the north of kudan road which is just
the bottom of the screen here and lar
Hill Road just slightly further east and
between fanbridge road on the west here
and to the west of pudy Hall Lane which
just that's pudy Hall Lane is indicated
here so it's to the west of that Beyond
neighboring Farmland to the north is the
river Crouch and the application site
includes part of the highway of
fanbridge road canum road and lill road
so this is along here um as underground
cables would be required to be laid
along these sections of the
highway the nearest residential property
to the site are those to the South um
here um and that includes roads
including a Rundle road and olon road
and in addition there is sporadic
residential development um just south of
the Eastern parcel um and and the
surrounds um fronting onto Canen road
and lill
road so this is the site layout plan on
screen and the Western parcel here
you'll see actually adjoins fanbridge
road and it also adjoins the site of All
Saints Church which is just indicated by
my light pen there the boundary of this
parcel otherwise largely follows
existing field boundary
the Western par sorry the Eastern parcel
is larger and will be accessed from the
South Via existing vehicular accesses
onto canum Road in this point here and
um just on L Hill Road here again this
parcel largely follows existing field
boundaries although part of the
northeastern boundary so this is along
this section indicated by the light pen
here um follows the edge of a public
right of way foot path which currently
bisects the large field there is an
existing solar farm development in this
locality which is located between the
two Parcels that comprise the
application site and the existing solar
farm is approximate in this location
here so to provide some greater context
the existing solar farm can be seen on
this aerial image so that's in this
location
here part of the eastern boundary of the
western parcel would border the existing
solar farm asward part of the western
boundary of the Eastern parcel so that's
in this area here and then this boundary
here the existing solar farm would
essentially be sandwiched between the
two Parcels however the new solar farm
would extend further north to
approximately this point here on that
aerial
image so the application SES you can see
is composed of Farmland which is
relatively flat and which forms part of
a wider sede of gently very gently
undulating Farmland along the southern
side of the river Crouch which is
designated as a coastal protection belt
in the adopted development plan the site
and surroundings are also designated as
green
belt so the proposed solar farm would
involve the construction of rows of
solar panels mounted off the ground each
of the blue colored box lines and if I
just um zoom into a section of this plan
here this layout plan hopefully you can
see those um box blue lines and they
represent rows of panels this plan sorry
I'm going just zoom out again um shows
approximately 100 14 rows so from the
north of the western parcel to the South
there's approximately 114 rows down
there access tracks would also be formed
for construction and maintenance traffic
and these are shown in Gray on the um
image on screen so you can see one on
this Eastern parcel just extending up up
through
there the mounted panels would range in
height from a minimum of between 0.9 M
and 2.8 M to a maximum of between 1.9
and 3.8 M the elevation on screen shows
the proposed minimum height solar arrays
at the top of the screen and the higher
solar arrays at the
bottom this site layout plan shows where
the different height solar arrays would
be located and a significant portion
would be at the minimum height which is
then the lightest color so that the kind
of colors come out a little bit
different on the screen but these are
all minimum height panels here as are
these here and these up here
as well as the solar arrays the
development would involve the sighting
of 18 Transformers these are pieces of
equipment that would be um housing
containers and these are shown as purple
rectangles on the site layout plan so I
I'll just zoom in because otherwise
that's difficult to
see so there that's still small but I'll
show you with the light pen so there's
two here if you can see the light pen
there and then there's two here which is
shown um with a bond around and I'll get
to that in a moment so and that's that's
spread across the
site so some of the Transformers would
have an earth Bond formed around them
and that's what I pointed out on on that
plan just there and this elevation um
shows an image of that some of the
Transformers would would not have the
bond around them
so in addition the development would
involve the construction of a fence sub
substation compound and this would be
located in this Western parcel at the
point where the light pen is indicating
on the screen there this would be
located close to fanbridge road and it
is here that the largest equipment will
be cited the Transformer here will be
housed in an acoustic enclosure which
would be 8 meters in height I'll just
zoom into that area of the
screen so hopefully you can see that so
this is the substation compound which
would be fenced this is where the
largest equipment is s centrally
positioned and this um rectangle here
indicates this acoustic um enclosure
around the Transformer
there so this plan shows a cross-section
through the proposed substation at the
bottom of the screen um and it shows the
8 m High Transformer enclosure indicated
by this sort of Gray colored rectangle
here the whole of the substation
compound would be enclosed by a 2.4
meter high Palisade Security
Fence a building is proposed adjacent to
the substation compound which would be
functional in appearance and the
elevations of that are shown on screen
and this would have a maximum height of
some 3.4 M A further building is
proposed which is shown on the um
submitted plan here to have a sloping
roof to a maximum height of 4.1 M and
this building would also be um cited
close to the substation
compound a 2 meter high security fence
is proposed around the perimeter of the
entire site and this would feature
security cameras mounted on poles at
intervals you can see that an an image
of that on the
screen so one of the key considerations
in the deter ation of this application
is the impact of the proposed
development on the Green Belt the
components of the proposed solar farm
including the solar arrays equipment
buildings and fencing would result in an
adverse impact on the openness of the
green belt creating built form on
otherwise open
land given the scale of development the
proposed impact on openness would be
significant the proposed development
would amount to inappropriate
development in the green belt which
national policy advises should only be
approved if very special circumstances
exist to clearly outweigh the
harm further harm would result from the
proposed development in terms of the
impact of the development on landscape
character and visual amenity the
proposed development would be visible
from a number of locations in the
vicinity of the site including from
nearby public rights of way the public
rights of way can be seen on this
extract of the public rights of way map
taken from the esset County Council
website and that's that's the extract on
screen the application site is located
in this of Central Area here and the
public rights of way are these sort of
pink lines that you can see um in the
vicinity of the
site um part of the eastern boundary of
the western parcel as previously
mentioned would run directly adjacent to
a section of this public right of way
foot path and from this foot path the
existing views of open undeveloped
Fields would be significantly altered by
the sighting of rows of solar arrays
very close to the foot path the
development here would give rise to
significant visual harm and whilst
proposed new hedge planting would
mitigate the harm to an extent a
significant harm would result
nevertheless there are other public
rights of we in the vicinity and the
impacts of those are discussed further
in the
report just take back to that
side so part of the application site
directly Bard is the site of All Saints
Church which is a non-designated
Heritage asset as a building identified
on the council's local list whilst this
is not a listed building the impact of
the proposed development on this
Heritage asset is a material
consideration the proposed substation
compound in which the larger equipment
will be cited will be cited close to
this asset a slightly great a greater
degree of separation is now proposed
compared to as originally planned as a
result of the substation compound being
um cited slightly further south and
planting would also take place between
the proposed compound
and um and the
church so if I just zoom into this area
again so what we have is the church here
the compound here these are all the
solar arrays and this is an area where
the Landscaping proposal does show um
tree planting and other kind of other
soft landscaping and that would be
further developed and and a condition is
recommended in respect of that
um the applicant has undertaken a soil
survey at the site and submitted a
report which relates to the agricultural
land classification the results of this
confirm that the land at the site is
grade 3B which is not included within
the definition of best and most
versatile agricultural land where
planning policy requires specific
considerations are taken into
account the land between the solar
arrays would be grasped and able to be
used for sheep grazing although the land
wouldn't would therefore no longer be
capable of arable farming an alternative
agricultural use would be possible
alongside the solar arrays it is also
noted that the proposed is for a
temporary or beit substantial period of
40 years after which the development
would be removed from the land and the
land able to be used once again for
arable
farming a soil management strategy will
be required to be implemented which
would seek to ensure that impacts on
soils at the site will be kept to a
minimum in terms of flood risk the
proposed development is considered
acceptable with regard to relevant
policy in respect of the impact on
biodiversity and and protected species
the proposed development is also
considered acceptable the applicant has
undertaken the required survey work and
the submitted reports have been
considered by the council's ecological
consultant and conditions are are
recommended when
necessary The Proposal would involve um
a soft land saing scheme part of which
I've mentioned that's in that corner
here but it goes much wider than that um
so so this um new Landscaping scheme
would deliver a significant extent of
new hedge
rows planting throughout the
site the proposed vehicular accesses are
considered appropriate subject to Essex
County Council Highway recommendations
um requiring appropriate visibility
spays and necessary planning conditions
in respect of that are
recommended the application site is
within fairly close proximity of a
number of Residential Properties and the
impacts of the on the residential
amenity of those occupants have been
considered that's all set out in the
report and there it has been found that
there no unreasonable adverse impacts
would
result so the harm that I've mentioned
in respect of the openness of the green
belt in terms of impact on visual
amenity and the impact on the Heritage
asset that harm must be weighed against
the benefits of the
scheme The Proposal here would deliver a
renewable energy facility that would
create up to 49.9 megawatts of power and
result in significant carbon
displacement which would be beneficial
in terms of helping to contribute
towards combating climate
change National planning policy
acknowledges that many renewable energy
projects in the green belt would be in
inappropriate development and recognizes
that in such cases developers will need
to demonstrate very special
circumstances which could include the
wider environmental benefits associated
with the increased production of energy
from renewable sources both National and
development plan policy adopts a
positive approach towards this form of
renewable energy development where harm
would be outweighed by the benefits and
the delivery of suitable renewable
energy projects is fundamental to
facilitate the country's transition to a
low carbon future in a changing
climate it is consider that the public
benefits of The Proposal in terms of
significant renewable energy production
are of significant magnitude to outweigh
the substantial harm that would result
from the development both to the green
belt and the other harm identified it is
considered that in this case the very
special circumstances do exist which
would clearly outweigh the harm and
justify approval of the
scheme so further to the addendum um
that that members have been furnished
with members are advised that there is
an outstanding response awaited from
cadent gas relating to the high press
pipeline that runs through the site and
this relates to an easement um which the
layout of the solar rays has taken into
account so if I just point out on the
plan this layout plan relates to this
little section here where you can see
white and no panels and this this
section here which also is white with no
panels proposed so the recommendation is
slightly altered but it we recommend
that um the director of place be
delegated to approve subject to the
recommended conditions following receipt
of a no objection from cadent gas and if
an objection from cadent gas is received
then the application will be returned to
committee for determination thank you
chair thank you Katie we have two public
speakers on this item the first speaker
is Mr LX who is speaking in support of
the application Mr LX please come and
take your place at the microphone you
have five minutes to speak and I will
give you a one minute warning when you
come towards the end thank
you thank you chair good evening
counselors my name is Matt LX planner
manager at low carbon the applicant I
wanted to start by reading a brief
statement from local resident who wanted
to speak to you this
evening I begin by speaking at this
committee I wish to reinforce my
comments made previously in writing that
this proposal deserves strong support
having had experience of the planning
system with this and other local
authorities I know that local residents
are quick to oppose applications but not
nearly so quick to voice their support
therefore as soon as I saw this proposal
I was immediately in favor of it and
felt it was something I should stand up
for in my opinion the proposed
development brings very positive
benefits to the local area with little
or no detrimental impact over its
40-year lifespan on a wider scale I see
the need for schemes like this across
the country to help us fulfill our
targets for Net Zero and energy
Independence I'm proud to live in a
district that has one of the top
recycling rates in the country by
granting permission to this application
I'll be even more proud that Rochford
District Council continues to prioritize
its green commitment and make and take
decisions that contribute towards making
the world a better place for our
children and grandchildren to thriving
thank you look
rest in terms of my my own speech um
start now decarbonizing in the UK's
electricity system will require an
extraordinary effort as one of the
cheapest and quickest forms of low
carbon electricity Soul has a key role
to play in meeting at zero as soon as
possible projects must be realized in
all regions if where to achieve it
provided their impacts can be made
acceptable grassland solar farm once
operational would provide enough
electricity to provide to power over 16
a half thousand homes every year which
equates to 45% of the homes in the
district however with electricity demand
widely expected to double over the
coming decade or so more renewable
energy will be
needed the district is around 75% green
Bel excluding urbal areas which will
make it difficult for the district to
deliver the renewable energy it will
need solar Farms are temporary and this
project will be fully removed at the end
of its operational life there are very
special circumstances here a combination
of the climate emergency the energy
crisis and a lack of any suitable
alternative
sites thank you to the council's offices
and the consules have worked with low
carbon throughout the development
process to design a project which is
sympathetic to inv environmental and
land use constraints mitigates impacts
on the local community and which also
creates Community benefit we have worked
extensively to understand concerns and
ensure that these are accommodated in
our proposals this we believe is
reflected in the low number of public
comment I'd like to talk a bit more
about the additional benefits the scheme
would would would bring a biodiversity
net gain of 50% this would be achieved
by planting 5.8 kilometers of new hedro
and planting over, 1500 new trees
development would allow sheep grazing
during its
operation the scheme would also have a
community benefit fund secured by short
form legal agreement which sits outside
of the planning
process again I'd like to thank offices
for the comprehensive review of the
application and the council more
generally for its
engagement your officers have concluded
that the project provides a positive
plan and balance where the benefits of
the project outweigh the
impacts councilors you have before you
today a well reive proposal that can
make a huge difference to the climate
and energy security crisis both locally
and nationally I would therefore urge
you to support your office's
recommendation and improve the
application thank
you thank you Mr LX if you'd like to
return to your
seat the second speaker is Mr French who
is speaking in objection to the
application Mr French if if you'd like
to take your place at the microphone
I'll you have five minutes and I'll give
you a one minute warning when you come
to that stage thank you thank you
members of the committee um grassland
solar farm I wonder what Brian
consultant th that one up nice RNG to it
doesn't it kind of place you might take
the family for a visit and a picnic
except you cannot as it would be the
industrial landscape fenced off from the
public and it's entirely inappropriate
in the green belt a better name might be
the largest solar farm of the country
which according to original plan stands
at 200 51 Acres it will be if not the
biggest then among the biggest solar
farms in the
UK interestingly enough the current Sol
largest solar farm shotwick at 250 Acres
produces 72 megawatt the proposed grass
lands predicted to produce only 50
megawatts which is some 30% less so it
would seem to me to be grossly
inefficient it's proposed to supply 16 a
half thousand homes with power are they
local do they benefit me you or
residents of the borrow do we get
reduced tariffs as a result of this
the land we're told is is agricultural
land 3B but is it that expensive to get
it back to 3A currently as far as I can
tell the land is being used especially
for growing crops why should we change
that so is there an
alternative as a general rule it takes
about 200 acres to generate the same
annual electricity energy through a
solar farm as just one offshore wind
turbine this represents a grossly
inefficient use of precious land
whatever its quality so the Farms do not
generate continuous electricity because
the random incidence of clouds over cast
Skies which districts electricity
generation from the panels in addition
the panels only work during daylight
whereas demand for electricity is
continuous for 24
hours with hardly any electricity
generated during the winter months the
average energy produced by solar farm is
only 11% of the install capacity of the
panels another gross
inefficiency in comparison a north wind
turbine generates over 40% of its rated
output on average throughout the year
and wind tur binds produce their maximum
electricity in midwinter when demand for
electricity is at its peak offshore wind
power is now recognized by the
government as a future for large scale
Renewables in the UK the solar panel
should also be encouraged not on
agricultural land but on existing and
future roofs and Wasteland particularly
where flexible thin film technology is
perfected for wrapping around buildings
the UK is one of the best locations for
wind power in the world and globally the
UK is in the top spot for total offshore
wind capacity due to its
location Britain's wind farms computed a
record 26.8% of the country's
electricity in 2022 and this will
continue to grow as more of these
offshore wind farms come on stream as an
example on the 10th of October of this
year the world's largest offshore Wind
Farm project started producing power to
the grid dogger bank is a group of
offshore wind farms located 80 miles off
of the oire coast in the North Sea when
completed in 2026 it will have the
capacity supply of 6 million UK homes
further a company called Aid already has
12 UK offshore wind farms producing
enough electricity to power over 7
million homes so if you can imagine
we're going to give up 250 Acres just to
provide 16 a half thousand homes so our
2026 both doer and AED will be able to
supply 50% of the UK's 26 million homes
with power now as far as I understand it
grass lands cannot go online apparently
until 2028 due to the National Grid
capacity restraint
further this year a study by the
University of Oxford concluded that by
2050 wind power provide
2,330 tatt hours a year this is made up
of onshore wind and also offshore wind
the combined figure of 23 2,330 tatt
hours is almost double the maximum
estimated final energy consumption of
Great Britain in 2050 which is 1,500
tatt hours a year one those 10 times our
current electricity needs of
299 hours a year why allow this proposal
to go ahead and see valuable land is
currently used for farming and being
built over a landscape blotted and
Wildlife impacted or the offshore wind
projects in use and being developed make
solar Farms like grass and's redundant
before they've even started further what
are the chances of the land being
returned to agriculture in 40 years time
potentially it could be used for
building on a large scale If This Land
Is Lost to food production now it will
never return to its Natural State surely
food food security is Paramount there is
an alternative to this grassland solar
farm and it's already here it's wind
power we do not need the solar farm in
Rochford thank
you thank you Mr French if you'd like to
return to your seat um Ward
counselors uh do we have any visiting
Ward members who would like to
speak no thank you okay uh committee
Ward
counselors councelor coun coun can I
just say to the ward members be to
councilors before we start um I've had
comment on not being able to hear from
the audience can I ask you to be that
close spread your finger and your thumb
that close and Direct in front of your
mic when you actually speak so as people
do stand a chance of hearing out in the
uh Auditorium thank
you uh thank you Mr chairman um had two
or three three comments about the solar
farm from local residents with a couple
of concerns one is obviously the church
is still a live church and it's a live
graveyard where people visit and there
is a concern with the noise from the
Machinery that's there secondly down at
the bottom part of the right hand
development there is a w Memorial to the
Lily B which was the American and that
lost their lives during World War II I'm
not sure whether that is actually within
the farm or just outside the farm and I
would like to put a note on the
development if it was to go ahead that
this area is treated with a bit of
respect and within that it is moved um
and they contact the local War
counselors to AAS with us on that point
um and thirdly the point where the
development or the developer now wants
to expend extend the time for their
development now rutford council's policy
is three years and I don't see any
reason why that policy should be changed
for this developer if they are not in a
position to be going ahead then they
should withdraw their application until
they are in that position and I would
therefore like to propose that the
amendment that was put is put in of
extending it is uh struck out
um do I have a seconder on that
please Council Miss sha is seconding so
thank you so we are now speaking to the
amendment does anyone have any comment
on that
please C refy if we strike this out from
the
application I don't see how the um
developer will be able to put this on
because it's not him who wants the extra
extra two years it's him waiting on P
networks to actually connect it to the
grid so if we strike this out I don't
know what the officers will be able to
doal on this so I'm against this
striking this out I think this is really
not a good idea thank you okay thank you
councel H yeah I I support um Council
conable in that I can we do the officers
have um information on whether or not
the neighboring site was five or three
years whether or not the other
applications go through I know there's a
few applications going through was one
in appeal whether or not they had the
three years or the five years
K this test um but I I I don't recall
the other ones being five years okay um
but if you wanted me to double check the
decision notices I can for absolute
Clarity because I should be able to get
that up in a second but it'll take a
minute uh could you give us the reasons
being why the applicant has asked for 5
years so yep um if I can refer you to
the addendum um page one part so it's
page one but it's the second Point um
and it it it says there that planning
practice guidance advises that a longer
time period may be justified for very
complex projects where there is evidence
that three years is not long enough to
allow all the necessary preparations to
be completed before development can
start so so it's not Council policy that
development um is given the standard
three-year time frame to commence not be
completed but just to commence um that
is a requirement of national um planning
law okay um but the planning practice
guidance which is again National not
Rochford allows local authori to
consider in some complex cases an
extension of that and the applicant has
um sort of of detailed um their reasons
for wanting that and that is set out on
pages one and then overly um on page two
of the addendum and what the applicant
is saying in specifically in relation to
this application is that this project is
dependent on an upgrade to the r grid
Supply Point um to allow full connection
they do say that a delay is not expected
at this stage but it would give them
flexibility um if a fiveyear um time
frame were thought reasonable um from
the committee okay one comeback please
sorry chairman just very briefly
um I believe that reason has been given
in other applications at least one other
application about connection to the grid
um they didn't request a five years they
were happy with three years as I
remember okay Council
award thank you chairman uh
fundamentally um I agree with the
fiveyear the necessity to have a
fiveyear how can I put it a fallback
position which I believe that is what
they're looking for I would assume that
if Ry grid which is on the other side of
the district is up and running then
obviously they will be able to complete
within the threeyear period but I do
understand they've got a lot of
technical difficulties it's going from
one side of the district to the other to
be able to connect up to the main Grid
at Ry so it makes sense to me to allow
the extra period that is needed just in
case and I think it's a reasonable ask
for a fallback position and to deny it
is actually to to Really preempt this
application coming forward and being
viable in my
opinion thank you councel ward uh
councelor C one come back yeah thank you
Mr chairman um when we had a briefing uh
on this solar farm recently for all the
members of the development committee we
was told by the applicant that they do
not go ahead with their building until
they have the uh where we've all to
connect within the grid and we was told
they already had that permission in
place if they're now saying they haven't
or it's not suitable for connection then
um I can't see what the problem is um
they've got three years to start the
project um if they haven't started it
within three years all everybody else in
the district has to come back and ask
for an extension for their planning
permission and I see no reason for this
company not to have to do that if that
is the case so therefore I stand with my
proposal okay I think we should take
that to a vote now so those in favor of
the amendment to deny uh the fiveyear ex
the extended 5ye on the application
please
indicate thank
you those who uh agree with the addendum
to allow the five years please
indicate
any
exensions that's five4 four against to
abstentions that uh is approved so that
will become part of the substantial
motion uh now do I have members who wish
to speak to the actual motion councilor
hoy hello I just try to be brief um I do
not that this is going to produce 49.9
megga wats of power which is generally
enough to override the very special
circumstan of green belt when I've read
inspector's reports they tend to go with
that however I've got concerns around
the sequential
testing they say it's done within 50
meters I just take advice from officers
is that fairly standard seems quite
close to the existing existing land that
they're using on that one the next one I
have concerns on were I'll just go
through the
pages noise has been dealt with it's
here somewhere it was on the um Place
Services historic building and
Conservation Area page
6.57 uh particularly I'll just go
straight to paragraph
3.20 um I'll just read that to conclude
the proposals are considered to result
in harm to the setting and significance
of a non-designated Heritage asset the
local Authority will have to take the
balance judgment with regards to any
scale or of harm or loss of to the
significance of the Heritage assets as
per paragraph 203 of the mppf so I don't
think that's really been addressed to my
satisfaction at this point unless
officers can give me more Comfort on
that then turning to the following page
6.58 and again I'll turn to the second
response
3.22 um Place services are not supported
on Landscaping grounds you have
significant concerns that the proposed
development in conjunction with other
notable schemes will have a significant
significant adverse visual harm to the
public RightWay Network note you put
foot pass
28- 05 oblique 05 and 280 oblique 09 as
well as the coastal Marsh landc landcape
Etc that's their fur so they my two
concerns and I'd also like to pick up on
what council conable said regarding the
L B I visited the L B with the scouts um
they walk there every year they have a
flag sent over from America every year
to lay there I I I I'm not sure how it
lies within this scheme but I would I
really like to know that that would
still be readily accessible by the
scouts I know it's not on public ground
but they always have had permission to
go there once a year thank you C could
you come back on those points please y
um so
let's not so let's take them reverse
order so the Scout permission um do you
mean permission to the use the public
foot public right of way the foot paths
you mean the actual land the Scouts have
permission from the land owner to use it
and I just concerned whether or not the
solar panels or the areas which may be
restricted would restrict them from
paying respects to the air crew of the
ready be sorry I missed that point the
War Memorial
yeah yeah I was trying to um and I think
um Ivon was trying to see if we could
work out exactly where the war memorial
is I don't know if anybody knows exactly
where the war would it be possible
chairman to put this as an informative
possibly and say that we've got concerns
and would they sorry can you get a bit
closer to your mind sorry
chairman um would this be possible to
put this as an informative then to say
that we that there we have concerns and
we we would like them to have
discussions with the scouts to make sure
that they can still access it um
providing it's not within the sort of um
I I don't think it is but I can't
confirm that because I don't know the
location of the war memorial but
providing it's not within the actual
solar farm enclosure you know the fenc
land which I think might be more
problematic in terms of allowing access
within the fenced compound um I don't
see any problem with an informative that
points out that a war memorial is within
the vicinity of the site and Care should
be taken um maybe in relation to
construction activities and whatnot um I
don't see any problem with that um in
terms of the essics County Council
Landscaping comments that you have
referred to which um conclude that in
their view the proposal would result in
significant adverse visual uh harm to
visual amenity with specific reference
to the public foot path um I think we
agree
um and we accept that and in the report
that harm is part and parcel of the harm
that has to be balanced against the
benefits so that's essentially what
needs to happen in the planning balance
considerations which obviously officers
have advised in the reporting concluded
um with a recommendation of approval um
so so that significant adverse visual
harm we say will happen um and then the
harm to the Heritage asset hasn't been
addressed it's well it it is it exists I
suppose in that consult te's or it will
exist in that consult
te's professional view so what you've
got is this um non-designated Heritage
asset here and it's and this development
they say will affect the setting of that
and we don't disagree with them so that
is other harm that would result and in
addition to that I think has a set out
there will be harm to the green belt
which I think members are you know um
aware of um and so that all of that harm
has to be balanced against the benefits
of this um development um and that's set
out the the only one that I am
struggling with a little bit is the
sequential test do you mean in respect
of flood risk I think you probably do 50
MERS I don't know if there's a reference
I'm trying to find that reference in the
in the report um and I I can't but a
sequential test would not take um and
just look at land within 50 meters of an
application
site um it's on page 6.40 paragraph
2.49
um the search area covered approximately
500 meters on either side of the
identified connection Point as this was
considered to be the maximum distance
between a connection point and a Sola
Farm of this
size to allow for a potentially viable
connection so I think this this section
of the report sorry is
um sorry let me just read that
section
sorry so I thought you'd said 50
meters so it says 500 meters in that
paragraph um and that's to do with um
there being a constraint in terms of The
Proposal in terms of the connection
point to the to the
grid so it's looking at other land
within that sort of area and whether the
whole this development could be
delivered on land that would be at a
lower flood risk so we say that the
sequential test is passed and the
environment agency raised no objection
on flood risk grounds so we're quite
satisfied that the development um would
meet the requirements of flood risk
policy Sor I just want to be quite clear
on that point I remember being talked
very extensively by Sean scran about
sequential testing um and I didn't think
that was part of it i' let that go the
only other point I wanted to make was
that there are 30 conditions on this I
seem to remember being warned a few
years ago about Planning by condition um
on one of our courses it does seem quite
excessive the number of conditions on
there which might suggest to me that
we're trying to get round the problems
of this by imposing conditions whereas
in fact if if you took out the
conditions it would it would not be
suitable so that's where I'm coming from
at the moment thank
you thank you councel
Shaw thank you chairman I did want my
first point was the memorial just to
make sure that the scouts or whoever
would like to come and do that do you
know do you know actually where it is on
the site I have been shown it but I
couldn't take it I would believe Roger C
would know councelor C would know more
than I would on that um but I have been
shown it
but no I can't see it but perhaps our
officers can do it but on the other
point I'd like to make chairman on the
condition and yeah you're right there is
a lot on
item 16 page 6.6
condition um it says about the
trees um and I was reading on page 6.58
3.24 and I had to read this a couple of
times because I did read it as I don't
know why because we talking about sheep
female black sheep I thought and it was
actually a rare female black po at the
site so the excuse me um can we make
sure that tree is in the conditions on
item uh 16 please condition 16 that that
tree is not going to be pulled up oh
whoops accidentally knocked it over by
contractor which does
happen Okay so that's on
6.58
3.24 about this
rare identified a a female black black
popular female black popular at the site
this is a very rare tree and if you go
to 6.6 with the trees can that bit put
be put in there please i' wait for a
response yeah sorry I'm just trying to
work out the page number so we're on the
condition that relates to um tree
protection is on page 6.6 condition 16
right let me just so that requires um
that no development take place until an
aricultural method statement and tree
and hedge protection plan has been
submitted to an approved in writing by
the local planning Authority um
thereafter only carried out in relation
to yeah that tree is not proposed to be
taken
out if you want specific mention to that
I don't see any particular harm so um we
could just I mean um where it says um
details of trees and hedges to be
retained and removed a um we could just
add something in there that that should
be um only those hedge RS because
actually only sections of hedge that are
to be removed um shall be as per the
submitted statement if you like that
they've already they've done an arric
colur impact assessment um and that
categorically says and we can say not
that tree it's not just that one we want
to protect although that's particularly
special yeah just thinking you know with
these
trucks on site whoops we've knocked it
down it's damaged it's got to come out I
just didn't want to make sure that tree
is protected thank
you thank you councel
new thank you chairman um KY on um
6.48
2203 um when it mentions the high
pressure gas pipeline I know you
mentioned Caden earlier but this
this part references the
hsse and awaiting a response which will
be reported on an addendum which I don't
think we've received the addendum for
that we we've got an addendum um what we
and what we hoped you would have is is
um an updated response from cadent gas
so the hsse the health and safety
executive is a is a Consulting
because of the high press gas pipeline
that runs through the site but actually
what um the consultation with the HSC
involves is planning officers putting
that through an an a web app if you like
that the hsse provide nationally and
we've put that through this development
through the web app and it it involves
plotting the site um and then the web
app gives you an output um and that on
both Parcels informs us that the HSC
does not advise against this development
and that's what we'd expect really
because what the HSC are seeking to do
is protect people okay from potential ha
major hazards associated with the high
pressure gas pipeline and this
development is not introducing
residential development it's not
introducing lots of a use that would
involve lots of people congregating in
this area where they might raise an
objection so actually the hsse through
that web app does not advise against
however to be cautious what we haven't
had back yet is a response from cadent
gas who actually sort of operate the
pipeline if you like um and they um they
have given us an email with a holding
objection back in May but the objection
doesn't talk of the email doesn't
although it says objection it doesn't
identify any concerns what it does say
essentially is that the Engineers
haven't had chance to review the
proposal so we are awaiting that but we
anticipate it being a no
objection because um the hsse web up
says they do not advise against and the
applicant has um you know sought to um
form a layout and and site
equipment considering that constraint
okay but what we are saying in the
revised recommendation is that if
members
determined the application this evening
we would ask you to devolve power to or
delegate Authority sorry to
um uh Phil um to issue the decision um
the director play Sorry to issue the
decision um once we've got a no
objection from cadent gas which I hope
to have tomorrow um or early next week
um but um just to ER on the side of
absolute caution and the final thing to
say is if we did get a different
response from them then it would come
back to you thank you members now we
have 10 minutes left in which we can
legally proceed therefore I will move a
motion without notice in line with
committee procedure rule 9N to ex uh
extend the meeting Beyond two and a half
hours for 30 minutes to complete the
remaining business can I have a
second councilor Shaw those in
favor
okay those
against okay we are extended for half an
hour chairman if I may I'll have to
leave after the end of this item if
that's okay I that's fine yes thank
you chairman just to let you know uh
Council Lyon has done the what three
words for the war memorial and we've
passed it over to the officers so they
know where it is
okay three words so we can't do that so
all right but at least they actually
know where it is that's Council in Lyon
found it thank
you while we're waiting for that does
anyone else have any comments they wish
to
make uh C refy thank you
chairman
um
solar panels make up part of the
diversity of energy generation including
wind and other new technologies that are
coming through and it's I think it's
really great that these companies come
to Rochford want to invest in roods for
these ways to generate electricity to
make us less reliant on carbon and
forign countries supplying our
electricity and makes us more
self-sufficient and I support this
wholeheartedly and I think it's
something we should we should embrace
but it's up to the rest of the committee
to make their decision and last plan
application I think that um we've
declared the climate emergency was
mentioned quite a few times and we have
declared a climate emergency and
hopefully way the thinking is at the
moment this is one of the ways of
combating that thank
you yeah councelor Hoy one one comeback
yes it's not come back it's just so that
councilors do know that we as a council
do have a policy on generation of of
electricity through SLE Farms which is
to reach
100 megawatt by 2030 we're at 60 now so
if we do approve this we would have
beaten our Target okay councelor
Ward thank you chairman um I'm glad that
um councilor FD just bought this up
because I think it's quite important but
I'd like to add something which um I
mean I've been looking into for a long
time um we're talking about land which
is 3B which is totally unsuitable for
agriculture but it's perfectly suitable
for this application coming forward but
I think what people need to need to
think of going to the Future we're
looking at land which as some people are
saying is being lost to agriculture but
this land is totally unsuitable for that
purpose but with a solar farm and I've
seen other examples it then allows
production of vertical farming which
then brings unsuitable land back into
production because it needs the energy
and I would urge members of this
committee to look to the future rather
than just looking at the moment because
this will enable greater production of
food through vertical farming because
it's very energy necessary and this will
provide that energy and I I would urge
members even though it's not within this
application it is something that this
application will allow to come through
later thank you
chairman okay thank you any other
comments okay um one of the things I
think about this is that uh when we're
talking about possibly losing land uh we
are in a position where this can be
returned technology will change over the
years and I dare say that there will
come a stage where this will become
defunct um but we have um an assurance
from the applicant that this Farm could
be taken out uh at later time um and
returned to agriculture one of the
things that I am aware of because I have
my factory opposite this particular site
is that the fields that are in the
biggest area of the application um are
not they've got they've had nothing done
with them um they're just land that has
just been left fellow um there's a a
friend of mine who actually used used to
use one of the fields for flying his um
uh radiar controlled aircraft um so
there's no um uh no farming being done
on that um I do think that uh we need to
consider it in the view of our climate
change our climate um emergency and that
we are dealing with
uh some of the um requirements that come
under that so I am in support of this
application and if there are if there
are no other members mission to speak on
it I would propose from the chair that
we uh move forward with approval um do I
have a
second Council Wilson Williams
sorry
um we're talking about the war memorial
now now now that it's been determined
where it actually is uh could you come
back on that please yeah so based on the
based on the what three words and we
have had it located it's it's outside
the site so I think it's
somewhere approximately down
here um yeah okay thank you and the only
other thing is uh as councelor Shaw um
suggested that we have an uh an an
inclusion I think it would be in the
item sorry condition 16 condition 16 uh
with regards to the uh tree that is
there that is special um I'm not sure if
if we need to actually vote that in that
can just be included in the conditions
am I
right this special tree can that just be
included in the conditions we don't need
to vote specifically in that do we no
okay all right okay so those in favor of
the application please
indicate that is
unanimous thank you members that member
that that motion the application is
approved uh we move on to uh item eight
um I would just say just in case there
is anyone actually hanging on the item
that has been
deferred that is sorry is been referred
to the committee uh the last item on our
agenda I am going to defer that because
of time to December meeting and that
will be in two weeks time uh apologies
to those who have come along to talk
about that I'm very sorry but we are
running out of time and there's a limit
to how how long we can concentrate I do
apologize but in the
meantime right we have 30 minutes to do
this last
application
um
sorry with item eight then we'll give it
a go but bearing in mind that we only
have half okay okay um here to go we
have no public speakers on this one so
hopefully we can get through this fairly
quickly clear would you like to bring
the so this application is a reserve
matters application seeking consent for
the details of a mixed you scheme for
residential and Commercial development
which is subject to an outline Planning
Commission granted on appeal in 2021 so
just to be clear is the principle
development here has already been
accepted um and we're looking at the
reserve matters um element of the scheme
so so the residential element is
described as a retirement village for
person's aged over 55 years as you can
see from the location plan the site is
Cherry Ed Brick Works a former brick W
site that has long been redundant
located within Rochford the areas
outlined in blue show other land within
the same ownership so the site to the
West um is a children's nursery that was
granted P admission in 2018 and the area
to the southeast um is a parcel of land
within the same ownership that will come
forward as a separate Reserve matters
application for commercial development
within the future to please Katie sorry
that's my thing if
you this is an aial perspective of the
site location to show the current
context of the site so immediately to
the South we have the airport Business
Park currently under construction you
can see the roundabout um accessway
there and some of the um facilities
already been built so Costa Coffee and
some other commercial buildings down
here um we also have a row of
residential dwellings bordering the site
here um Cherry Ultra Country Park here
um and Ashen football club up here and
the parcel of land just here is an area
of land um owned by South n city council
and is also within the joint eror action
plan for employment use we have um Plan
Three please Katie thank you um can you
zoom out slightly so I can see the whole
thing thank you so this application
seeks approval of reserved matters
relating to scale Landscaping layout
appearance and internal access the main
access points for the site are located
to the Northwest so here Southwest and
the South they've already been agreed as
part of the outline application and
they're not for reconsideration as part
of the current application they're also
now proposing a link here which is an
Eastern link which would link through to
the South End city council land which we
don't have any information about um what
that would be proposed to be developed
like just yet but it provides that
connection Point through to it so the
proposal includes a 93 bed care home
with its own car parks that element of
the scheme is located here
the sorry
93 sorry I'm trying to go a little bit
quicker um it's a 93 bed care home
located here um as you come around the
access road we then have to the rear
here on Northern boundary 22 twostory
dwellings and there would all be
two-bedroomed then to the south of those
this is a collection of nine Bungalows
um again all two bedroomed we've got
open space here with a band stand Lo
located here other areas of open space
scattered about here and then along this
Eastern Edge um are five four story
blocks um they've the first four blocks
have commercial at the bottom and then
residential above and the last one just
has residential um the first two have
sheltered accomodation within them
sorry um the second two have assisted
living and the fourth one also has an
element of retirement apartments and the
fifth has um solely retirement
apartments located within it um the
commercial for blocks 2 three and4 has
not been detailed but the description
refers to class E which covers a whole
manner of different uses that Forin
commercial business and service um block
one houses um the convenience store and
GP surgery at ground floor level and
they were a requirement of the outline
Planning Commission so that would
provide some immediate services on the
actual application
site move on to plan four please
Katie thank you so this shows an
elevation of what the care home would
look like and that's the entrance way
into the site um perspective so the
building will be staggered in height um
it have a four story element on the
Southeastern corner so that would be
away from the existing development and
the proposed Bungalows would provide a
feature corner there and we've got
glazed entrance Lobby here as well move
on to plan five please ktie thank you
this is just an example of um one floor
of the layout here so um it would have
various communal uses so you'd have an
internal BR level just be an internal um
uh area here for the external area for
them to use Courtyard um ter teres we
would also have lounges and dining areas
proposed um bars a bar and a cinema area
as well and the possible operator is
considered to be runwood home so it's
been designed with them inspect in um as
the potential end user move to plan six
please KT so this is the elevation of
the Bungalow so we're looking at quite a
modern appearance with a steep pitched
roof modern use of materials and and
good glazing level and looking at plan
seven um this is the um dwellings which
have a very similar look to the
Bungalows but we also have each of them
would have a carport here um a first
floor Terrace as well located here um to
provide some amenity spaces along with a
rear Courtyard and balcony as well and
if we can look at plan um eight please
KT so the five mostly mixed use blocks
all have a similar appearance with four
stories and the use of balconies and
material changes to break up the scale
and appearance of the elevations so each
block would use a different color
cladding to create visual interest
blocks two to four would have ground
floor linkages to the commercial to
create a continuity of Frontage um if we
move on to plan nine please
KT so this is block five the one that
would have the um mostly the or solely
sorry the retirement um Apartments
within it um it would have a roof
Terrace this is the main difference
between this and the other blocks um um
here and there' be two structures that
top provides um access to and from the
roof area there if we can finish on Plan
Three KY
please um so the key material planning
considerations are layout including
residential amenity provision of
commercial floor space amenity space
dwelling mix and refu and waste storage
scale which includes technical housing
standards internal access including
vehicular and pedestrian access car
parking and cycle and power to wheer
parking appearance landscaping and other
matters it should be noted that changes
have been made during the course of the
application to address design and layout
concerns raised by officers now the
applic the officer's recommendation does
go in detail into all of the different
material considerations listed there um
so I'm not going to go through each um
element um separately to explain those
because it's all listed in quite a lot
of detail within the report um but what
I do need to just add to is on the
addendum there was reference um from
ess6 fire rescue with regards to access
to the North Western corner of the care
home and making sure that had sufficient
um access from a fire Appliance
perspective um the agent provided
additional plans to confirm that they
would be able to accommodate for that um
and that has been accepted by S fire and
rescue um so they are content with that
now so the recommendation is that
director of place be delegated to
approve the application on the expir of
the outstanding consultation period and
subject to the conditions outlined in
the recommendation and addendum it
should be noted that the site notice
expires tomorrow so the consultation
period has only one day left to run
officers are presenting this to members
ahead of the expiry as the applicant has
advised contractual obligations
necessitating a decision at this meeting
that are time critical and May otherwise
threaten the project it was considered
reasonable to do so in this instance as
the site already has outlined permission
for the principle of development and we
have not received any neighbor responses
so far to the consultation process
however if the council do receive a
response is considered to be material to
the application such as a neighbor
raising concern around potential
overlooking then this application will
be returned to committee for
consideration thank
you thank you Katie uh Ward counselors
have councelor Williams would you like
to speak
first thank you chairman no nothing
other than I should have declared a
nonary interest on this thank
you thank
you visiting members would you like to
or visiting member I should
say okay thank you councelor Ward thank
you very much chairman I I do welcome
this and I do have personal experience
of run rum or ronwood homes isn't it um
my mother-in-law was in one and they are
superb and I think anyone who actually
ends up in one will be treated well I I
just got one question for the officers
uh in regards to solar I was looking
through the app um is is there solar uh
on on the roofs on the area uh within
this particular development is that
mentioned in any way because I did I
couldn't find it we don't have detail at
this stage but it is a condition that
was on the outline application um as far
as I which actually required that level
of information to be provided so we
that's something that we'll get in as
part of a discharge for the outline orbe
it we obviously got a bit more detail
now with this current application if I
can just then put into the equation um
because I've been very interested in net
zero and housing and such like um I I've
I've noticed that in in a lot of
occasions now coming forward you
mentioned cladding on the front of of
the apartments um I've noticed that in
in some of the new design instead of
using cladding which I know has got a
strange name at this moment um it's been
using fire resistant solar so it
actually is able to take um the light
and use that light to up upgrade the
Energy Efficiency of the building I I
would like that to possibly be
considered as an alternative and in fact
it works out a bit cheaper I believe
than than cladding from what I
understand we where we have the
condition um on the outline as far as I
call I'll double check in a moment with
regards to Renewables um then I think we
could use it there we also have a
condition around materials as part of
the application suggested as well um
before members tonight so I think that
could sufficiently accommodate um
consideration of materials it may not be
what we end up with it depends because
obviously we're looking at the design of
it as well AB but I think it's something
that potentially could be considered
would it would make the development
extremely energy efficient that's what I
was looking at actually as far as that
question thank
you okay thank you I think that that can
obviously be part of the conversations
going forward so thanks for pointing
that
out Council
Newport thank you chairman does feel
like a bit of a rush job this one if I'm
honest um presentation was extremely
fast
um
what I do have um a bit of a concern
here and I don't know if we can do
anything about this but that's makes a
lovely car park for the airport
visitors
and I do have a concern about how
parking is going to be controlled with
on that site is that something we can
deal with um this
stage all right okay that's okay then um
and the other issue that I was going to
raise um just following on from
councelor
Ward is the EPC rating of the buildings
uh building regs issue or is that
something that would come in no planning
yeah be building rigs that would be so
we don't but we don't know what EPC
rating knows that's going to be built to
no no not at the moment okay thank you
okay Council FY thank you chairman I
can't believe anybody has not mentioned
Street seene this is not Rochford this
looks like a
European but tail blocky sort of thing
it's I don't see Rochford there I just
don't see it it's I can't think anywhere
else in Rushford that looks anything
like that I don't know if you can put me
straight on that but the street scene
just
doesn't I
think sorry when in the design access
statement and know where the um
developer been going with they've been
trying to create these like kind of
micro characters on the site the site is
sort of like unique sits on its own to
an extent really um it's not kind of
bordering Watford um so I think it had a
potential to create a more unique
appearance to it and I think with the
design access statement has sought to
use new materials but also try and still
bring in the element of brick work um
obviously characteristic of the former
brick work site within their design I
think that's um that's their um design
principles and design coding really
around um around
it can can I just come back I'm not I'm
not against I'm not against it I think
it's a good development I think it would
create jobs anything else I voted for it
the first time but I just I just don't
think it's
very the street scene is is is great
thanks counc
Williams thank you as the point that
councilor Shaw made is um this was
originally intended to be a gated
community I'm pretty certain that that
was refused at um outline planning isn't
G as far as I'm aware it was done an
appeal no it's not a gated
community okay how we doing we any more
comments sorry so that does take me back
to my original question about
can as in the planning stage can we look
at how parking is restricted on that
site I mean that's it would be largely
down to the actual maintenance
Arrangements of the site itself mean the
the the um the sort of a lot of the
roadways Etc will be private along with
parking areas and they will have their
own maintenance and management company
um associated with that so it would be
controlled um privately through through
those routes so so that site is not
going to be built to adopted standards
it it's not it's it will be built to
adopted standards but I don't think the
prop proposal is to put it forward for
adoption they're intended to keep it
private I believe it's the plan so
therefore the parking area would remain
that way remain that way too and
there'll be a c they'll need an element
a large degree of element of parking for
the to support the actual development
itself as well so I'd be surprised if
the actual management company would want
to lose anything to airport parking on
sure they want to control it themselves
separately right so it just brings me
back to um a point on that where if
management company then decide to
enforce a permit scheme is that
something we can condition I'm just in
theory talking about it because I just
want to know at the planning stage if if
we can condition against that sort of
thing or I think I mean to be honest I
think it could still potentially be
reasonable when we do still impose um on
like res on residential major
development schemes um the use of car
parking spaces to be retained for
parking of vehicles only for example I
think we could probably on this one um
require that it be only used for the
parking of vehicles in association with
this particular site I think that
probably be a reasonable condition to
avoid it still be someone visiting the
site
it I think I think um Collective view is
that it is down to the management
company it potentially wouldn't be an
enforceable condition that would meet
the tests if we were to impose that so I
think we need to stick with the view
that it' be down to the management
company councelor Ward yeah if I can be
of some assistance on this one um if we
look behind where Marks and Spencers and
the new establishment there that has uh
parking restrictions which are actually
only allow those people who live on the
site or are visiting that site
and that is managed privately and that's
in the whole area so you know I think
it's doable it's down to the management
of this developer and how it's done uh
it's it's outside it's their private
concern in my
opinion C
Ry this this is probably about three
miles away from the airport entrance
this is nowhere I don't don't see what
anybody in their right mind would want
to par there to drag their
cases about three miles to the airport
entrances lot closer
places just making that point okay I
think that I think we've done that one
to death now um so we need to move on
from that um just a personal comment
when um the vice chair and myself met
with officers on the premate I did
actually uh express my opinion it same
same as councelor FD that I thought that
that especially the the five blocks were
particularly ugly um and not in keeping
with Rochford but it is something that
unfortunately uh it appear Place
Services very happy with so um we we
don't really have that much of a say on
that sort of side of things um I think
we need to move on unless there's anyone
got any other comments because we are
getting close to time now um
so with uh regards to the
application
recommendation is to approve the
application subject to conditions set
out on pages 8.1 to 8.12 of the report
and Pages 7 to8 of the
addendum um I will move uh approval from
the chair do I have a second Council
award thank you all those in favor would
you raise your
hand those against
thank you any
extensions thank
you that is six for one against four
abstentions that application is
approved and with that and being as how
we only have 10 minutes left as I said
before I'm going to close the meeting
there at 20 past 10 thank you for your
attendance tonight everybody and for
your patience excuse me I the last one
that we've had deferred for the next
meeting can we have that on the as item
agenda mom please I will ensure that is
so thank you because we've got visiting
uh counselors that have been waiting
here all night and we haven't had put it
through
understood